we looked at a whole slew of problems
when we came into office and we've said
where can we advance the ball down the
field each and every time across the
board and we don't score a touchdown
every time but we move the ball forward
you're always going to fall short
because if you're hitting your marks
that means you didn't set them high
enough hope is imagining and then
fighting for and then working for what
did not seem possible before that's
leadership John F Kennedy didn't look up
at the moon and say oh that's too far we
can go false hopes Martin Luther King
and stand on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial and say go home everybody the
dreams deferred false hopes you all need
a reality check there is a moment in the
life of every generation when that
spirit of hopefulness has to come
through if we are to make our mark on
history you just watched two amazing
clips from Barack Obama take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]